tu ça tisse un kiss kiss ass est partie
de tout ce qu'il y à là dedans là dans
ma tête parce que on n'arrête pas de me
dire qu on est vraiment plusieurs donc
j'ai beaucoup de personnalité de
conscience comme on dit dans qui ça et
un jour bons mais j'étais tout seul chez
moi même je me suis dit bon qu'est-ce
que je peux faire genre de faire quelque
chose d'un petit peu innovant et je me
suis dit bon ben je vais faire parler un
petit peu tout ce qu'il ya dans ma tête
donc je faisais d'avoir un bon petit
smartphone un petit peu comme tout le
monde et en voyant les vidéos j'ai un
réalisateur avec qui j'ai travaillé sur
une autre route série s'appelait le
garçon de chambre qui a lui maintenant
une production qui s'appelle la
production et les jtc qui m'a dit écoute
c'est génial allons faire évoluer salon
fermement début pur vidéo un super
tournage avec des moyens pour qu'on
puisse voix l'afp faire évoluer son
concept de conscience de qui parle à un
sujet et ex qu'on a sorti je n'ai pas
d'ambition pour notre rêve le problème c
est moi j'ai pas d'argent être en couple
ces projets ratés kemp achètes tu t'es
pas seuls dans ta tête un ballon que
loana franchement ça vaut pas le coup
ça m'énerve il ya plein de gens qui m'en
parlent alors ce soit des métropolitains
des antillais
toute sexualité confondues parce qu'on
va vraiment dans tous les sujets on est
vraiment on aborde tout tout tout ce
qu'on veut tout ce qui nous plaît tout
ce qui nous fait rire surtout que ce
soit par rapport à ma culture que ce
soit par rapport à l'air du temps
et voilà il donc ça parle quand même à
pas mal de gens et on se dit bon bah on
va continuer vous saviez ce que j'ai
fait q quand j'étais gamin avec mes
cheveux l'ars en tirer une éponge je
peux toucher à la latte et donc en fait
des métis surprise et au bouquet michaud
x 100 ma des poils de ce sont tes vrais
handicapés à sedan pas touchés et ce
quand je paie tous mais non tu peux pas
toucher bordel de merde un tipi donc
c'est un système de croo funding on va
dire qui est plus basé sur le base c'est
vraiment selon l'envi des gens chacun
met ce qu'il veut en fait ça quand même
avec une toute petite équipe ça te
demande tout de même des décors sa
demande du matériel surtout qui n'est
pas notre disposition pendant qu'on loue
donc on a besoin vraiment de ça pour
pouvoir donner un produit fini de sa
qualité
évidemment en tant que petite structure
nous ça nous aide surtout ça nous donne
une avance et nous après on met derrière
pour c'est mon petit bébé non cash
il faut mettre ce qu'il faut là où il
faut